[Music]
[Applause]
told you we just reviewed a fantastic
for a movie I'm not doing another one
but it was so bad I don't care
they couldn't even spell it right fan
for stick okay you got half a percent
I'll buy these meetups how the hell you
do that it found a way like nerd yes no
that one what are you doing the storage
closet I'm here to do the Ninja Turtle
movie review with you an angry video
game nerd remember I don't care if the
nerd is a bigger star my face should be
bigger than his I'm the title card come
on who's the bigger Ninja Turtle fan to
me hey Craig our unit turtles crossover
with the nerd yeah sure come on out I
don't care if I don't know anything
about that one show or that one or that
one
hey another one I totally didn't know
that but nevertheless I am the biggest
band and I deserve to be bigger on the
title card everything about me is bigger
than him pulling that weight you've been
in the storage closet that entire time
it's not so bad I still made videos hi
I'm Andre and I'm a black nerd today I'm
gonna be reviewing boxes again yay boxes
wish you think it's better cardboard or
plastic they both keep you alive if you
ever need to eat them
like I do I'm so cold
you think that's bad
how about the topic of cutaways so are
you finally ready to do the review oh we
reviewed that a few months ago didn't we
yes but seeing how I could be facing
some serious criminal charges for this
let's go ahead and do the crossover
anyway it could be any movie you want
Smurfs
any movie you want Smurfs any movie you
want Harv's I'm sensing an earth girls
are easy vibe from you
Smurfs troll 2 it is a little cliche but
I still think we can get some good
material out of it hello police the
staff to critic it out another black guy
again it's true that's stupid
then Oracle did not eat what I heard
that CEO the Belgian comic turned into
an American 80s cartoon has finally hit
the big screen well technically the
second time fucking wires like will see
these cartoons have banked more on
selling merchandise rather than focusing
on interesting stories you take that
back
it was mostly harmless so much so that
I'm not entirely sure how you could get
that much of a movie out of it at least
without being super creative well that's
exactly what they did at first
rumor has it paramount originally owned
the rights to the movie and we're
looking to make it sort of a comedic
epic fantasy think Lord of the Rings
meets Princess Bride well that doesn't
sound too but until Sony got the rights
to the movie so Alvin and the Chipmunks
with a big hit and said hey we could do
that just make them blue so wait they're
just ripping off that terrible movie no
all that's missing is the crowding turd
would you like to buy some Smurfs
merchandize evil takes many forms this
is a Smurfs movie it opens with a
narrator Smurfs no there's a smurf
called narrator Smurfs at least they're
not hiding they're lazy in this as he
talks about a place that knows no
sadness well clearly it can't be in this
movie
a place inhabited by beings oh so it is
an animated movie
no that's CG is supposed to look as
convincing as the human characters
really they all look like Rockies coach
if he had met the mclubbe in amia it's a
fake read a book at first everything
seems to be par for the course The
Smurfs she recognized are all there they
all have names that match their one
personality trait and even the evil
Gargamel played by Hank Azaria plots to
catch them
ah that evil entity who wants to destroy
the Smurfs essence in order to become
disgustingly rich hey I was talking
about Gargamel not Sony actually in this
version he wants two Smurfs essence to
increase his magic not to make gold or
eat them and as you can see he's not
very good at it as he spends most of his
time playing with puppets rather than
getting any real work done hey at least
they look more real than the actual
sparse
get a boy well any kids film that opens
with cat falls on a beloved characters
head is certainly setting the bar pretty
high
Papa Smurf voiced by Jonathan winters
has a vision of all the Smurfs being
destroyed because of a mistake clumsy
made never realizing that maybe he made
that mistake because you named them
clumsy mushi
yeah it's like naming your daughter
prostitute are you really encouraging
any great things labeling them that
actually one of the stranger things is
the people they got to play most of the
Smurfs
oh come on celebrity voices are
everywhere are you really surprised that
people like Katy Perry and George Lopez
are in this for the main characters no
but what if I told you that pee-wee
Herman himself Paul Reubens was in this
what where right there and now he's gone
what they called him in for just two
lines he got the deluxe treatment half
of these celebrities barely even got a
word that was Kenan Thompson but there
went BJ Novak huh oh there's Jeff
Foxworthy
there's Wolfgang Puck 1 don't miss Joan
Rivers knew her infront of course John
Oliver's one incredible line oh please
tell me is there to do a report about
how this movie is ruining America I
think it speaks for itself you're right
so Gargamel finally figures out that the
Smurfs have kept hidden because of an
invisible force field
yes we've gone from children's fantasy
the Star Trek technology but some of
them stumble across a magic portal don't
act like you haven't where Gargamel has
them trapped looks like you got the dog
that did the stick this time
hey much rather sacrifice my life than
listen to your heinous performance
because it makes much more sense to
chase six Smurfs as opposed to
ninety-four this leads them to where
every fucking portal and family films
leads to New York City preferably the
very pretty and or intimidating part why
are we suddenly in an episode of How I
Met Your Mother
oh don't you know this is Neil Patrick
Harris his movie now what I thought this
was about sports
well critic like most sellout
adaptations the title character really
has anything to do with the title itself
so instead of being about little blue
people it's about an advertising VP
coming to grips with becoming a father
so we're in a romantic comedy that just
happens to have Smurfs
yep that's like having a holocaust film
that suddenly decided it needs Fraggles
that comes out next week
I hear Oscar buzz I need you all to stay
close I know it should be making fun of
the product placement but honestly I'm
just thinking how much better this movie
would be if bloom Angra play The Smurfs
but they wouldn't talk exactly and just
when you're wondering if watching a cat
vomit will be more fun than watching
this movie the film decides to answer
for you
infinitely more fun yes it's like the
Disney world of fun in this movie am I
the only one getting a bald Moe Szyslak
from an unfunny version of The Simpsons
so the Simpsons now apply well I must
find a laboratory
it's about the buggy could darkened
terrible magic in them so even worth
wasting a joke on that no move on while
he tries to figure out how to get the
magic out of her hair
Neil Patrick Harris visits his pregnant
beard while the Smurfs try to break in
and this part takes and what I'm
noticing more and more in bad family
films especially in Raja Gosnell films
movement pull what your anti movement no
I'm anti lazy movement movement that
only exists just to hypnotize your kids
rather than engage them engaging
movement involves a lot of variety sharp
stops varying speeds unexpected turns
this is what makes good visual
storytelling here everything is at the
same speed the same pacing and the same
kind of movement there's no variation so
there's nothing interesting about it
what's more engaging watching Mario go
one speed throughout the entire game or
having him stop slow down go backwards
stomp on things this safe boring and
repetitive movement is the same as
looking at a watch waving back and forth
they're both trying to hypnotize and
relax you so that you don't think about
what you're watching and that's not what
a movie is supposed to do you're
supposed to think about it you're
supposed to be sucked in but this method
is an ingenious way to numb your brains
without feeling bored so you think it
must be doing something right when
really it's just junk food for your mind
and it's all over the movie oh I don't
know I don't think there's anything
wrong with a constant source of movement
hey guys as you probably notice there's
a jump cut there and there and there
some might say it's a fast-paced way for
me to save on memorizing line it is Papa
feed random thing if you know how hard
it is to do I Chester is that why you do
the best anything is that what it is I
thought it was just a wizard you never
question how you could do this when
you're as high as I am you learn not to
question things
subscribe are we a magazine no we're
just supposed to saying I'm a whore
[Applause]
you
[Music]
the slut spot talent and decide to
attack him honey hell I think they're
gonna do me in the Smurf
so he's told who the Smurfs are and big
surprise he finds it all kinds of
confusing sticking with you this is
actually happening theory that's
actually a legit question I always had a
theory that all of this movie was just a
continuation of his drug hi from Harold
& Kumar Go to White Castle
no not even a drug person would go this
far without smashing them you wanna get
high ya hear that honey they're only
staying til an actual blue moon rises
which could happen if the little blue
Santa man makes a magic potion which at
this point seems completely plausible I
don't think that was in the script
I think Harris was just clarifying how
horribly written this movie is and
you're all named after your
personalities do you get your names when
you're born or after you've exhibited
certain traits yeah yep oh I see so
clumsy has the personality trait being
clumsy grouchy has the personality trait
of being grouchy as summer fete has the
personality trait of girl girl as well
no girls just have one personality trait
says so much about her I love how
they're shocked that she can wear
different clothes but not that she's
pregnant having only one female made
from nothing do you think they can even
comprehend the idea of a pregnant woman
yeah you think in this movie they'd go
more into how Smurfs procreate
I say wizard I say artificial Smurfs a
nation I have all the answers right here
your loss there's some mighty fine blue
balls in here I had to write on the
cover cuz you're not ready yet to see a
smurf get smurfed in the smurf
those Smurf stands for anus but like
most of Harris's performance he acts
like he wants to get out of every scene
as quickly as possible a crazy morning
so tell me Patrick is that Smurfs in
your pocket you're just happy to see me
I need to hone my message here get it
come on none of you find that song just
the tiniest bit annoying I find it
annoying did you just laugh at a Smurfs
movie no just like on a Smurfs movie no
just remember every time you live in a
Smurfs movie God kills a kitten it's in
the Bible huh I don't know how I miss
that it's an art cover it reads a little
different than the soft cover Gardner
will uses a Smurfs hair to make his
magic better catching the eye of
Harris's boss played by Sofia Vergara
oh my god this is really happening
people what do we do let's look away I
can't it's too awful close your eyes in
a match while your kindergarten sits not
pissing into a bucket mm-hmm it's a
working for you pail with rolling it is
gravy neither there's only one oh it's
so much better for some reason yeah me
too
but I feel like we're missing part of
the movie oh you're right you're right
let's for wine and see what we missed
the Smurfs end up in a toy store where
of course all sorts of misunderstandings
take place I'm just tired of the whole
dating game just say who you are okay
first that looks nothing like a smurf
second it's not even blue third does he
really not know it's a pillow he has to
know it's a pillow I mean is that
something that Smurfs don't know they
just don't know what pillows are they
have to have pillows their hands are
kinda like pillows I mean for the love
of God how is this even remotely
possible who gives a shit ah thank you
1998 Jennifer Lopez you're right the
more I questioned it the more I chose I
care Oh
baby they weren't looking for a
stargazer two dresses Wow she seemed to
get past the impaled heads and
supposedly dressed up corpses pretty
fast must be that defined girl
personality Gargamel tries to catch them
but then ends up getting tased now that
has to be funny Gargamel getting tased
good God
how can a movie possibly screw this up
like that you couldn't even make
Gargamel getting tased bunny he sounds
like Professor fig getting jerked off I
don't think we need that image no I
don't think so either
Oh much better oh but I feel like we
missed part of the movie in their spare
time Smurfette reveals her troubled past
I was created by Gargamel to trap the
other Smurfs and then we Reverend pop
has saved me he cast a special spell and
then helped me become the Smurf I was
meant to be Oh
so much for her backstory yeah who cares
we have harris's advertising job to
worry about it's not like this movies
about Smurfs time to either celebrate or
file for unemployment I think that was
the banner at the movies rat party but
we don't need to worry about that for
too long as we partake in more movement
porn which also conveniently serves as
trailer fodder and product placement for
a guitar hero and/or rock band
[Music]
was the Neil Patrick Harris crotch cam
really essential to the scene I'll
accept it as long as the Smurfs don't
rap as long are they even singing - I
know it's supposed to be like a music
video but in terms of the movie they're
just rapping into a corner yeah plan if
someone was down there looking at us
look amazing you look like you're being
punished doesn't it break you out
sometimes little guys depending on you
that's what being a public is there's a
saying goes we just Smurf it you're
raisered Gargamel is put in prison which
let me see if anything funny is
happening here nope as he magically
summons an army of flies to save him
[Music]
even by summer standards that's just
weird but it looks like clumsy
accidentally tripped and sent the wrong
design to the firm as most trips do
which means the wrong ad is sent all
over town you said that they would bring
good luck this is anything but good I
never should have let this happen I
never wanted a house full of little
people running around no it's ok I only
just meant it as a metaphor for the baby
of all the people in the planet those
magical little creatures came to us they
chose us don't you see how absolutely
amazing that is
this is a once-in-a-lifetime thing
Patrick this is our Blue Moon you know
it's amazing you are 100% wrong I mean
nothing you said has been right yet
Kurt's right nobody chose anybody
yeah it's clearly just a series of
accidental circumstances forgive it this
though it does make me crave blue moon
let's go drinking after this nothing
that wasn't given but thankfully Times
Square is full of ironic imagery and he
realizes that hammered in messages are
good meanwhile at an old bookstore the
Smurfs are looking for a book of spells
which seems to be really enough a Smurfs
comic book secret runes are hidden in
the drawing you see all that in there
look here so wait pale wasn't just a
cartoonist he was also a dimension
jumper or was he a time traveler didn't
this all take place in the past kind of
and upon his discoveries all he did was
make cartoons about it I know if I say
this but Smurfs you're kind of hard to
follow Gargamel tries again to capture
them but Papa Smurf stays behind to get
captured why he couldn't just escaped
with them well then it wouldn't feed
into the Papa sacrifice he talked to
they head earlier that doesn't mean you
get purposely caught for no reason
doesn't it black nerd doesn't it well
the director Beverly Hills Chihuahua
says it does so shocked have you seen
Beverly Hills Chihuahua no have you but
they get the portal to open up and bring
tons of Smurfs back to save papa yeah
that doesn't really work as a war song
it sounds more like a lullaby from
Donald Trump hmm an angry horde of
people holding weapons chanting and
wearing pointy white hats for some
reason I feel very uncomfortable while
that's going on Papa Smurf is being put
through a machine to extract his essence
was that a smurf thing being afraid of
onions no was there an episode when Ivan
killed his family no could be onion no
why the fuck is he afraid of onion I
don't know Indiana Jones is afraid of
snakes but not produce there's not a
scene of one of the movies where he's
like onions why did it have to be onions
let's just agree that the writers were
probably on meth when they wrote this
there's no probably about it bloomin
blue meth want to get high
yes oh but here's something neat we get
to see how Azrael gets the chipped deer
but wait if this happened after the
cartoon shouldn't there already be a
chip deer I guess it makes as much sense
as Smurfette saving Papa Smurf only to
immediately have him captured again
heist this guy throws himself into
trouble more than Bella Swan but clumsy
is about to perform the action that Papa
Smurf saw would doom them all visions
except when they're completely wrong
like this time just put that in the bag
of other plot holes this movie doesn't
explain really it's getting so bad I owe
you an apology from Z I believe more in
a vision
from now on you shall be called
semi-competent Smurf this leads to the
Smurfs finally being sent home I should
get going
I've got a Smurfs village to rebuild
your village has given me some ideas
we're thinking about putting our garbage
on the street and acting like assholes
to anyone who looks at us funny really
so that was the Smurfs movie but only by
title this has so little to do with the
original cartoon believe it or not in
2017 they're rebooting the Smurfs again
and fully animated and more like the
source material which makes perfect
sense cuz this movie has nothing to do
with the original Smurfs look you do
have a Garfield you know with the chip
must but the Smurfs lived in a medieval
fantasy world with dragons with wizards
with witches with magic with sorcery
with adventure and you decided was more
entertaining to have advertising
executives domestic parenting New York
City Sony product placement that is not
what the Smurfs stood for it was magical
it was timeless and you made it to
thousands and yet it was such a big hit
why I'll tell you why because they threw
a lot of money and advertising at it
with no effort people forget how all
over the place the Smurfs were it was a
marketing monster that couldn't be
escaped it grabbed older people's
nostalgia younger kids love for toys and
enough celebrities to have people sure
gonna be way too forgiving because of
how cute it was so wait you're saying
you can make a bundle through no effort
at all as long as you just advertise it
right pretty much all you need is
something nostalgic celebrities and
someone who's manipulated people through
advertising before coming this fall to a
theater near you ped Rock it's your
childhood favorite like you've never
seen it before it jumps around to pop
songs looks cute wraps in the corner
alter some white idiots live and all
while having a ton of celebrity voices
you remember these people age group 5 to
37 don't you it's Amy Poehler
Christopher Walken call me Chris Chris
Rock Selena Gomez the rock wants what it
wants
hey she said the thing and of course
samuel l.jackson yeah I'm in everything
so why not be in this mutha fucka but
you don't want a movie called the pet
rock to be about the pet rock so we have
several characters to derail the plot
like Neil Patrick Harris as the ad
executive Megan Fox is April O'Neil Shia
LaBeouf
from Transformers all right eesh they're
just about to ride with Natalie Portman
and Courtney Cox in a pink convertible
with human and Thor in the backseat with
a soundtrack featuring The Rolling
Stones get Rob and other rock related
names you know it must be good it's on
fucking everything bedrock the movie
it'll turn your heart of stone into a
heart of home coming out the same
weekend
[Music]
[Applause]
that camera still on
hey guys dog walker here you know every
time I doing this dives are critical lot
of people tuned in and I really wanted
to do something good with that and
something I want to try that's kind of
new is that I want to give a shout out
to certain charities that I think are
really worth your attention of really
worth your support so I'm gonna do that
at the end of every video now I'm gonna
give a shout out to some really special
charities preferably ones that I know
something about our pets in contact with
and that's exactly what I'm gonna do
here I'm gonna start off with a charity
that is very very special and they're
just we've seen them work first and
they're phenomenal it's one step camp
org and this is a camp for children who
have cancer here at this camp you're
just a regular kid and you can just feel
like a regular kid and we've seen it
firsthand cuz you're not seen as anyone
different you you're like any other kid
and all these kids come together and
they share so many incredible
experiences and I remember we were there
on the last day it wasn't wasn't a dry
eye in the house I mean it was just
seeing all these kids come together just
having fun and hugging each other I mean
that they're saying goodbye and they say
goodbye to each other and it was just it
was the most heartwarming thing you've
ever seen I mean it's just incredible
and these people do such great work so
if you have the time definitely go check
out their website and check out the
wonderful things that they do we've done
charity drives for them before and we
talk to them in person they're just
phenomenal people and they are
definitely worth your time to check out
so if you can definitely go take a look
show your support and donate to
something that is absolutely wonderful
you